someone asked thoughts on minimalism
um
minimalism
isn't the thing uh
there was a time period when
if you wanted to be
internally free you had to be an ascetic
you had to renounce things you had to
you know if you look in old buddhist
societies they basically go out with a
begging bowl
and they do that because at some level
to be happy your your reality has to
exceed your expectations so you just
reduce your expectations down and you
reduce what you need but modern society
we're a lot richer even those of us who
think we're poor aren't really that poor
we have iphones we have
tvs we have roofs over our heads we
still you know take uber pool or you
know get on a bus or have a scooter or
something so
real poverty if you're watching this
broadcast you're probably not in
real poverty
so
minimalism is no longer required what's
required is just
that your expectations still have to be
below your means
so you know one of my better tweets i
think is where i wrote that
people who live far below their
expectations enjoy freedom
that people who are busy upgrading their
lifestyles can't fathom
and what i'm basically saying there is
don't keep upgrading your lifestyle
every time you make more money
try to live at least one solid notch
below what you're earning
and then the little things won't bother
you as much and you can achieve a lot of
the same peace of mind that people used
to have to give up their entire lives
and families for
do
you